welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka death Vader and
with the rise of Skywalker premiering
last night we actually have six big
images that have been leaked online
throughout this video we're gonna be
going over what's in the photos and
additional plot spoilers that have been
posted on Twitter obviously you know the
drill by now there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here and with the movie just
two days away you might want to skip
this video if you haven't had anything
ruined yet without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of the leaked images and plot
points okay so basically to paraphrase
Han Solo the leaks were true all of them
I can't post the photos in the video
here just because Disney will block it
as if seen actually happened with a
couple of youtubers today but basically
what they do is confirm the leaks you
want to see these images and all you
need to do is go over to reddit.com
slash Star Wars leaks and yeah the
images are all there just google reddit
Star Wars leaks and you'll find them all
so the images that have been put up so
far are two pictures of Emperor
Palpatine in which he looks like how he
did in The Return of the Jedi but they
painted his face completely white and
put yellow and red contact lenses in so
he looks like he's got Sith eyes he
looks very old and very frail and he's
also sat in a mechanical chair there's
also an image of the Wayfinder which was
the big MacGuffin that led kylo to find
the Sith Lords hideout and in addition
to this from the end of the movie we see
Leia and Luke's lightsaber on Tatooine
the most notable image in them no that's
probably more important than all of
these and definitely confirms the leaks
is that Rey has a yellow lightsaber if
you've seen the entire plot League
breakdown that I did then you'll know
that the movie ends with their holding
it and calling yourself Rey Skywalker
and yep this image confirms it I always
thought the yellow lightsaber thing
would be the make-or-break element of
the plot leaks as it was a big point of
contention that would be very very
unlikely that someone would make it up
but as we've seen from the leaks it's
true and yet Rey Skywalker in addition
to this twitter user call me Ben swallow
has also been posting leaks out about
what happens in the film and I'll just
be going through their post
talking about what they said okay so
they're tweet read some more
confirmation that yes kylo dies after
his Redemption Kyllo revives Rey they
smile at each other
she says Ben and they kiss kylo
disappears like Luke when he dies they
do not say I love you
kylo holds her sweetly when he brings
her back to life and says the force bond
is stronger than ever
Oh Twilight all over again
Rey is the granddaughter of grandpapa
pulps she takes the name Rey Skywalker
at the end and the whole scene on
Tatooine is true Rey having BBA at the
end isn't explained finn and power alive
but they're not with her in the final
scene Leia and kylo have no scenes
together
ray stabs kylo during their fight at the
same moment that layer dies and ray
cries and heals them after Han is in the
movie and Anakin's voice is in the movie
with the character being voiced by
Hayden Christensen Gianna isn't
confirmed to be Lando's daughter which
was a plot point that we did mention in
the leaks Pole lives Knights of Ren are
hardly in the movie and the user doesn't
remember them having any dialogue they
don't really fight Palpatine yes he
shoots lightning in the sky but radius
ends up reflecting this to kill him
nobody ends up with anyone in a romantic
sense and the movie doesn't explain how
Palpatine is back we find out Palpatine
created Snoke and there are a couple of
tanks with snow clones in them as we saw
in the leaks however the user says that
nothing at all is explained which in my
opinion is very very lazy writing like
yeah just you can't expect the audience
to just jump on the ship with no
explanation all you do need a plot
points in place that kind of flesh those
things out as they are things that
people have major questions about but
you know I knew they were going to do
that anyway I knew they'd be lazy and
just say I am still here some some crap
like that very lazy feel like I'm a
teacher telling someone off anyway kylos
reaction to seeing ray dead it was
panicked and hurt it was well acted with
still so awkward because of pacing the
user says that ray Loewy had honest
moments that could have been so hot if
they'd been handled better I'm Shae Mo's
hot I was waiting on them hot moments
the way they talk to each other was kind
of wink wink and the force bond was
really strong so that was cool
the only force ghosts are Leia and Luke
at the end
Leia's last word is Ben Luke's ghost
also appears to catch Ray's lightsaber
when she throws it away
rey ends up fighting dark grey which was
a vision and this sequence is on the
wreckage of the Death Star the opening
scene is actually the kylo on the Red
Planet scene and it has very little
added context he's there to get away
fine it is that land and immediately
arrives there and it goes straight in
the scenes from the TV spot that's
literally just that's the that's the
opening of the movie rose and Rey don't
speak to each other and there's
apparently an LGBT moment in the movie
that people have been kind of gushing
over on Twitter and that is apparently
that a woman that is close to layer and
hold Oh kisses another woman in the
background at the end which which I mean
if you're looking for representation in
this movie it kinda it kind of feels
like they let you down it sounds like
they're just trying to get the pink
pound by putting this very little moment
in and there's actually no real weight
to it which classic Disney just just
trying to put things in for the sake of
it to get money anyway the user says
it's implied that finn is going to
confess his feelings for Rey but it
doesn't happen Rey confides in Finn and
prefers him over Pole because she
doesn't get along with him han appears
to kylo and they have a very similar
conversation as the force awakens bridge
moment even down to the dialogue Ben
also says you're just a memory and Han
says your memory and touches his face
then Ben turns and tosses his red saber
away and this interaction turns him the
lists of deaths that they remember Abu
leo Huck's pride layer Ben snap Wexley
Rey temporarily dies and Palpatine Ben
comes to save her from becoming Empress
Palpatine which yet that was another big
plot point that we heard we kind of roll
her eyes at and he revives her when
pulps kills her Ben never wanted her
dead and she instantly regrets stabbing
him Palpatine is waiting for right to
come and kill him so that thus it can
inhabit her body and when she gets
rejuvenated she kills the villain
there's a flashback scene of Luke
training lair in the force and
lightsaber combat and she even had a
saber which force ghost Luke gives to
Rey Rey steals Ben ship on the Death
Star and takes it to act you bless you
to hide out there forever like Luke so
she destroys it so she can't leave then
she goes to throw a saber into the
flames but ghost Luke catches it
gives it back and then lifts the x-wing
out of the water and that's how she gets
home in the scene with the voices of the
Jedi come to a Dre they tell her to rise
and that she has all the power of the
Jedi Anakin's voice is there
so his Mace Windu's Yoda's obi ones as
well
c-3po gets his memory back he can still
understand sit script but is forbidden
from translating it so they hack his
memory at the swiping it he tells them
where to find the wayfinder and he
forgets everyone and everything but his
memory gets restored by r2 it's also
implied that Finn is force sensitive
Kari and Billie share is seen together
when they talk about resistance right
it's stuff and that's all of the posts
that the users put up so far so yeah
that's all of the leaks from the
premiere which pretty much confirms
everything that we already knew about
the film and adds in some little tidbits
and a couple of changes but yeah for the
most part it's pretty much bang on white
posted last week so make sure you head
over to that video after this if you
want a full breakdown now honestly just
thinking about how bad this entire leak
has been I genuinely think we're gonna
find Kathleen Kennedy dead in the next
couple of days with a pair of white
Mickey Mouse gloves next to her because
I have no idea why security was so
lacking across the board here you have
actors leaving scripts and hotels leaks
just getting out months ahead of the
movie reshoot updates then breaking the
internet and now photos actually been
taken at the premiere of the film like
where was the security this entire time
I'm not even joking I actually went to
see Ford burst Ferrari a couple of weeks
ago and there was a security guard
standing watching the entire cinema for
the full movie we got told before going
in as well we'd be in trouble if we were
even on our phones chewing the trailers
and yet these people are taking photos
at the premiere at the end of the movie
it's just kind of crazy to me that this
whole thing got leaked and I have no
doubt that Disney will be mad because
yet they're normally air tight on
security Lucasfilm back in the days to
arrest people for even stepping on the
Skywalker Ranch in case they were
getting leaks and this entire movie has
been out in the open for months now it's
just baffling how it all got out I mean
this is meant to be the end of one of
Disney's flagship franchises and the
entire thing has been so mishandled
I don't see how there's not gonna be a
lot of mass firings across the board I
think after the hype has died down we're
gonna see some resignations like you you
know the type where they say it's a
resignation but they got sucked and yeah
I just think heads are gonna roll now
will the movie be bad um I think it'll
be okay just okay I don't think it'll be
a badly made movie it'll probably have
some very crunchy moments in it but it
won't be flat out I can't even say it's
gonna be terrible in it but we're gonna
see but what a mess this entire thing
has been now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the rise of Skywalker
leaks and if you're still gonna go see
the film or not comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please give it a thumbs up and as I've
said about 50 times in this video make
sure you head over to the pot league
break down after this if you want to
know all the ins and outs of the movie
if this video made you turn at the dark
side then please give it a thumbs up and
if you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which would be
linked in the description below we drop
videos on there early so if you want to
see stuff before anyone else and that's
the best place to be it's pretty
adjoining we have an awesome community
so hopefully I see you over there very
soon we're also giving away a free copy
of Joker which is one of our favorite
movies of the air and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning it's
like the video make sure you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the leaks in the comment section
below
the one it's gonna be chosen the 15th of
January and the set will be shipped out
from then - ever gets the prize so best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is the channel for people who were mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]